not taking it very seriously as Fox News.
Yesterday, I had video of you of Congressman
Devin Nunes s suggesting that the Corona virus
pandemic is a great time to go to restaurants
because they won't be busy.
You'll be able to get right in and get yourself
a beautiful table.
We now have video of the buffoons at Fox and
Friends, which Trump watches.
Remember saying this is a great time to fly,
despite warnings from every public health
organization in the world saying the opposite.
First reminder, this was Devin Nunez.
We played this clip for you yesterday where
there's a lot of concerns with the economy
here because people are scared to go out.
But I will just say, one of the things you
can do if you're healthy, you and your family.
It's a great time to just go out, go to a
local restaurant.
Likely you can get in, get in easily.
There's you know, let's not hurt the working
people in this country that are relying on
wages and tips to keep their small business
sympathetic, run to the don't run to the understand,
just don't run to the grocery store and buy
buy, you know, four thousand dollars of food.
They're going to go to your local local pub,
very sympathetic to what's going on.
So now let's get to Fox and Friends.
Here's Ainsley Earhart on Fox and Friends.
It's actually the safest time to fly.
Everyone I know that's flying right now, terminals
are pretty much dead.
Ghost towns and then the planes.
Remember back in the day when you had a seat
next to you possibly empty.
You could stretch out a little more.
It's like out on every flight now.
What do you mean?
When I used to fly years ago.
You mean the plane?
Yeah.
Right.
My wife was flying yesterday.
Every seat on the plane was taken.
Really?
Absolutely.
And Megan, who was taken there were people
are leaving New York to head down to Florida.
Why wouldn't you?
Yesterday, the mayor declared a state of emergency.
So there it is.
Great time to fly.
And notice Steve Doocy adding idiocy to idiocy,
saying we have a state of emergency here in
New York.
Why not go down to Florida, spread germs on
the plane and then spread them in Florida
where they didn't, at least as of then have
a state of emergency?
Unsure at this point what's going on in Florida.
People congregating at beaches.
People going to concerts, people going to
bars, restaurants spreading, spreading, spreading
Florida.
Increasingly a cluster of corona virus infection.
Irresponsible people.
And remember that Fox News's own audience
skews older.
Is it a good strategy to suggest your audience
behave in a way that will kill them off and
thus hurt your ratings?
I mean, this is obviously it's all immoral
and unethical and wrong what they're doing.
But even from a business strategy, does this
make sense, make it likely that the people
watching you will be more likely to die if
they follow your recommendations?
And I really hope that Donald Trump yesterday
during his press conference admitting that
Corona virus is not under control, that we
are possibly in a recession, that people need
to stay home.
I hope that this is going to make an impact
because too many Republican governors, plus
the clowns at Fox News plus Rush Limbaugh,
plus the rest of them, they've been almost
urging people to ignore the recommendations
from doctors and public health officials and
pandemic infection outbreak experts.
Those are the people we should be listening
to.
Not Ainsley Earhart and Steve Doocy.
These people are dangerous.
This is not a joke.
This business plan of theirs will kill their
own viewers.
But this is a sort of negligence at a mass
scale.
I don't know how this can be called news of
any kind.
And of course, there is no distinction on
Fox News.
Between news and opinion.
And in reality, they claim there's a distinction.
And you have people who are not only at particular
risk if they do this and they fly and they
go to the beach and they go to restaurants
and do all this stuff.
It's not just that there are people because
of both ignorance in our country, Fox News
not distinguishing between news and opinion
and the fact that people can't tell the difference
between news using opinion.
In many cases, you have people who think that
that's news they see they see Ainsley Earhart
saying it's so convenient to fly right now.
They consider that equivalent to a doctor
specializing in infections saying something
different.
It's equivalent because of lack of media literacy,
because of Fox News deliberately blurring
the difference between their news and opinion.
It's kind of all infected with with opinion
anyway, as we know.
And simply because of the ignorance that is
so widespread in this country.
The reporting about Corona virus on Fox News
has been and continues to be a public health
hazard.
And we're going to have more clips on the
show's Instagram page.
I encourage you to follow us there at David
Packman show.
And also, I posted my work from home setup
yesterday to my Instagram.
David dogtag.
Follow me.
Check it out.
Let me know what you're doing.